et aujourd'hui on se retrouve pour une
nouvelle vidéo sur garry's mod cette
fois sur le mode murder si jamais vous
n'avez jamais vu une vidéo du vote le
retour de karim wade que dont vous ne
comprenez rien la vidéo j'ai rappelé les
règles de la description vous allez voir
c'est très très simple alors je vais
vous dire ce que je suis le mec parce
que bien évidemment sans mentir parce
que moi je mens jamais dans le jeu bon
ok voilà donc je suis encore une merde
ça me saoule mais il s'est à chaque fois
fait demi-tour il m'énerve attendre je
connais du monde c'est tous égaux je
vois ça a tancé les sortants couteau
l'avait dit rien sorti mais qu il
s'arrache et hugo vasile goût vient pas
de cette vie tu es tu qu'elle veut mais
c'est pas moi mais elle vous me saoule
et ça c'est sympa mois dernier vers
clermont se regarde j'adore des anneaux
suite avec sa tête de psychopathe
vas-y je suis encore le vieux binder
carrière pour tous qua non est la tête
et c'est un c'est golfe du
mexique
je suis encore ce de beille
stender de merde ça ça veut dire
chez le père de enfin là au moins c'est
vrai que je n'ai pas été sur les chaînes
sur le dos c'est hugo je vous jure c'est
hugo ou jetés dessus pas au cinéma pas
mon cas c'est sierre a passé ses
horaires je dors et déjà tué mon gars je
suis derrière lui les flammes mais à
part l'amérique mais je trouve situation
et des cafés le 4 mai histoire été
battus - vas-y tu moi je suis papa tu
pas ma fille je l'aï royal on ne dit pas
qui a tué qui me tue pas parce que je
suis derrière les gars c'est la mort sa
position et l'eau met ko ses co seco
c'est hugo c'est une culture non médias
plutôt à du café par jour alors la
grosse qu il un gros ce qui la situe
matin après robert salchow mais
l'oreille tu dis rien c'est le meurtrier
comme ça
dans sa tête il est comme ça vient à se
cacher médias non j'ai pas qu'on ait les
mêmes usines cote en suisse profite à
goma proches pas et comme approche pas
au yen à diverses espèces de campeurs de
mer ont fait route sont par les six
banques et qui vont l éleveur tri bouge
toi le cul pour faire attention c'est
marrant danger encore un de bail
sender avec le vert bravo à vous laisse
moi sortir d'ici week-end la formation
car et il marche pas je vais la grille
qui saute
moi je suis lui dû au hasard mais aucune
raison qui tue moi qui ai les mecs ça
suffit jean lé nom lundi paraissait
normal il a cru aller à la boulangerie
là dessus et je vous jure 4 août que je
suis rien et voilà et là je vais dire ça
ils vont croire que ces mois encore
comme lui l'asie je dis qui je suis de
ckoi pour le prix que c'est pas moi que
à des tiers allez
voilà et arrêtez de me tuer pour la
troisième fois qu'un témoin sur le toit
là je vous jure je vous dis que je suis
mais ça fait six fois marque un pic aux
études islamiques atteste de sa fiancée
luc tu vas te faire des tests de
confiance à hugo non non non cette
adhésion à ces gosses rien la vie de ma
mère je télécharge en était fière de toi
tu habites issus des buteurs ben c'est
pas moi d'un couteau la traversée dure
mais je prenais juste à côté de toi
laisse moi monté laisse moi et arrête de
regarder les grands yeux
regarde comme vous y allez
à 7 ans il était le canon il a volé mais
c'est à quelqu'un eut beau mais non
c'est toi tu l'as dans les mangas mais
ne l'est pas c'est à tan dun hugo nom
ait alors via stratégie tout péter ceux
de 2003 ou de gueule santander avec un
viseur laser sur mon front avec autour
des îles étaient partis en exploration
minière où est donc cette vidéo tu peux
pas faire ça et je me levais et au jeu
de paume à la tuer à les profiteurs a de
la merde pas de ce côté pas ce côté pas
fait attention voilà
et voilà les gens c'est bien prendre ce
petit best-of sur le mode murder de gaz
mode jet pack ne vous aura plu et que
éventuellement vous aurez un peu a ri de
manière un peu moins faux cul que ça on
se trouve marc du maire-coppeaux
nouvelle vidéo merci d'avoir gardé celle
ci jazz band bis
à bientôt emporté à boué
[Musique]
et